congratulations you've taken the
seven-month long journey and have
finally landed on Mars and it turns out
you're the first person better start
cleaning the place up and getting it
ready for human colonization will you
ever make it back to earth how will you
gather resources for survival and will
this happen someday this is what if and
here's what would happen if you were the
first person on Mars a trip to Mars
might happen sooner than you think NASA
is hoping for it to be as soon as 2033
think about that the first person on
Mars might be watching this video right
now hello future Martian and NASA may
not be the first to get there there are
plenty of other space companies trying
to get to Mars around the same time
similar to what we saw in the 1960s with
the moon it's very likely that we'll see
another space race only to Mars this
time but getting there is the boring
part now that you've landed what happens
next
your first goal will be to set up base
and it can't just be anywhere
researchers believe that the best place
for a camp on Mars is near the planets
poles there you'll find massive ice
deposits which are thought to contain
large amounts of water we need water to
survive but it's heavy and it takes up a
lot of room on a spacecraft so to solve
this problem we could potentially turn
this ice into water that we could drink
study and use scientists suspect that
the ice deposits may also contain iron
and sulfur which could be used for
manufacturing in the future but that's
in the long-term for now let's worry
about your base being built luckily you
won't be building it as space companies
intend to send a team of robots up there
to assemble the base for you after
that's done you can finally move in the
base will be roughly 12 meters high and
5 meters in diameter
that may sound pretty roomy but you
won't be alone
space companies are planning to send six
people to Mars for the first expedition
at least you'll have people to talk to
while you're there once you've landed
you'll quickly notice how different Mars
feels from Earth Mars has just one-third
the gravity that the earth has nASA says
that a person who weighs 45 kilograms on
earth would only weigh about 17
kilograms on Mars you'll be able to jump
all around the planet but if that's all
you expect to do this trip won't be for
you the first people on Mars will be
unlike any astronauts we've seen before
apart from knowing everything about
physics and spaceships they'll also have
to be farmers botanists and excellent
problem solvers one massive problem
they'll all need to solve food
production let's hope you like your
vegetables because aside from astronaut
food that's pretty much all you'll be
eating a University in the Netherlands
simulated crop growing on Mars and found
out that potatoes peas carrots and
radishes could all grow on the planet
you'll be able to use the soil on Mars
and water will come from recycling urine
and whatever other water products were
brought onto the planet and speaking of
human waste unfortunately you'll have to
use your poop to fertilize the crops
you're growing now that's recycling
after about nine months of researching
farming and exploring Mars you'll then
begin your journey home
this is arguably the hardest part of the
trip you and your crewmates would hop
into this Mars ascent vehicle or MAV for
short
then you need to line it up perfectly
with the larger spaceship which is
orbiting Mars the ascent up to your
spaceship could last as little as under
a half an hour or it could be several
days it all depends on whether you can
line up the MAV with the larger
spaceship and if not done correctly
things could go very very bad but if all
goes according to plan
think of what you've just done you were
the first person on Mars and after
living there for months
what you
learned will make it easier for future
generations to live on the red planet
permanently but what would happen if
instead of going to Mars you went to
Venus well that sounds like a story for
another what if